in this day and age collaboration is
somewhat of a buzzword but in reality it
really works and that was very important
for me to cope they were very passionate
about being in the similar space
MediaCorp decided to move to a new area
in media palace in one north and the
biggest challenge was actually the site
which was much smaller of 1.5 hectare so
we're dealing with perhaps a quarter of
the land area and therefore the scheme
required the facilities to vertically
stack if you go to other broadcast
centre in other parts of the world they
will never have theater press radio and
news all housing on building so that's
why one of the challenges was to
incorporate all of them in one going to
keep them separate stratified different
kinds of programming and
responsibilities and yet being
interconnected in that way as well when
you look at broadcast centers throughout
the world many of them tend to be
industrial type buildings and not
particularly places where people come to
visit now in this case a media Corp
wanted to engage the general public
through showcasing the operations of
broadcasts by having a tour around
allowing the general public to opt
through now this is very unprecedented
to take on this kind of building and
making it public and friendly and making
an attraction which does not exist in
Singapore and potentially this will put
this on a global map making it a very
unique facility
you
[Music]